le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
être une maman apporte sans doute les
plus belles émotions dans une vie mais
quand cette vie se complique avoir des
enfants en bas âge devient chaque jour
une source d'inquiétude
travailler pouvoir faire garder mes
enfants un parcours chaotique pour cette
femme célibataire
trois enfants à charge un seul salaire
et l'un des plus gros soucis la garde
des enfants
les crèches sont là pour ça des
structures dédiées à la garde mais aussi
à l'éveil des enfants mais la crèche ça
coûte cher ça peut varier en fonction
des années des parents qui se présentent
Stéphanie peut-elle réussir à surmonter
ses difficultés
doit-elle faire un choix entre garder
ses enfants et poursuivre une carrière
professionnelle qui peut l'aider on en
parle maintenant dans lien social
Youssef a moins de trois ans il ne va
pas encore à l'école ces deux sœurs plus
grandes sont déjà scolarisées pour
Stéphanie qui s'est retrouvé seul avec
ses trois enfants la vie et chaque jour
un parcours du combattant
les enfants sont sa joie de vivre au
quotidien Stéphanie aurait pu être tenté
d’arrêter de travailler pour se
consacrer totalement à sa vie de famille
mais elle a fait un choix courageux je
n'ai pas eu à choisir entre travailler
et rester chez moi parce que j'aime
travailler donc peu importe les moyens
que j'aurais emprunté j'aurais travaillé
donc j'ai lave mes enfants seuls c'est
très speed on va dire
il y a la crèche l'école la garderie le
centre aéré un drame familial l'amenait
à affronter seule la réalité de la vie
mais stéphanie est une battante pas
question de lâcher son travail les
grandes vont à l'école pour Youssef le
plus petit la crèche semble être la
solution la plus adaptée pour Stéphanie
ça serait ça serait bien pour eux ça
serait beaucoup de bonheur
nous sommes là pour accompagner les
enfants tout au long de leur
développement et s'assurer que que tout
se passe au mieux durant le temps que
les parents nous confient leur leurs
enfants une crèche c'est un
établissement conçu pour accueillir les
enfants dès leur plus jeune âge les plus
jeunes ont trois mois seulement
c'est lorsque la maman doit reprendre le
travail après un congé maternité que
l'enfant découvre bien souvent la crèche
nous avons 30 enfants inscrits à la
crèche de trois mois à 3 ans et demi
jusqu'à le départ à l'école dans une
crèche la sécurité de l'enfant l'hygiène
la formation du personnel sont des
priorités plusieurs organismes ont donné
leur agrément après un contrôle très
poussé ouvrir une crèche ça ne
s'improvise pas il faut l'accord de la
commune pour avoir l'autorisation
d'implantation ensuite l'agrément de du
conseil général qui s'obtient en faisant
la demande auprès de la PMI le médecin
de PMI passe à la structure et s'assure
que tout est dans les normes pour
pouvoir accueillir les enfants pour
fonctionner les crèches reçoivent des
aides de la Caisse d'allocations
familiales et de la commune dans
laquelle elles sont implantées mais
leurs sources essentielles de revenus ce
sont les parents eux-mêmes qui
l'apportent nous avons les aides de la
CAF et de la mairie en plus de la
participation des parents une
participation parents qui dépend du
niveau de revenus pour Stéphanie la
crèche revient à un peu moins de 100
euros par mois pour pouvoir faire garder
Youssef une somme importante à la crèche
on lui a conseillé de se renseigner sur
le chèque marmaille
chaque Marmagne nous permet de diminuer
le mensualité au niveau de la crèche
payer plein pot la crèche ça reviendrait
à donner pratiquement la moitié de mon
salaire ce qui serait vraiment trop
onéreux et qui me permettrait pas de
vivre correctement le chèque normal est
une aide directe au bénéficiaire et le
montant du chèque 70 euros permet de
régler une bonne partie de ce que coûte
la crèche pour un enfant si la facture
est supérieure à 70 euros en plus de ce
chèque marmaille il aura à payer la
différence si le parent a une facture
inférieure ou égale à 70 euros il n'aura
qu'à donner à la structure le chèque
marmaille grâce au chèque marma je
permet de travailler sans me soucier de
la garde de mon petit dernier parce que
le chèque Mormant il nous aide beaucoup
au niveau finance au niveau financier
pour la garde du petit l'échec normal
représente une aide pour les parents
pour leur permettre d'accéder au mode de
garde pour leurs enfants
le Conseil général n’a pas dans ses
missions le financement des crèches par
contre dans sa mission de soutien à la
petite enfance il aide directement les
bénéficiaires sous la forme du chèque
normal et cette année le chèque normal a
été revalorisé à hauteur de 250 euros
pour un enfant porteur d'un handicap le
chèque par mail permet à Stéphanie de
placer Youssef dans un cadre sain et
sécurisé où il apprend la vie en société
et qu'il amène progressivement vers
l'école un dispositif simple et efficace
pour faciliter le quotidien de bien des
familles réunionnaises
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais